ich weiß nicht leute wenn ihr es wisst
schreibt gerne in die kommentare das ist
stand was kreisky davon herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja
würde ich hoffe natürlich jedes gut mir
auch danke wir machen heute den vierten
part von essens aus aller welt
essens testens test
das ist ja wirklich das ist es also mit
so vielen essen drin kommt mit mit so
vielen essen drin der komplette spiel
gerade naja egal
auf jeden fall haben wir hier wieder
eine box wir können uns ja eigentlich
schon hinsetzen
das ist hier eine snack ochs ich glaube
die meisten von euch sollten das jetzt
mittlerweile auch kennen die bekomme ich
mal zugeschickt und anni dass wir zum
ersten mal schauen da ist dann immer ein
land drin aus diesem land kommen dann
ganz viele süßigkeiten getränke was auch
immer da rein und alexa von auspacken
und euch vorstellen
und heute haben wir wieder ein neues
land die box ist schon auch ich habe
aber noch nicht reingeguckt wir schauen
jetzt mal was es wird und ich lege auch
ans herz auf jeden fall die letzten
papst zu schauen wir hatten japan kanada
das war das letzte irland also da sind
schon verrückte sachen dabei und jetzt
bin ich mal gespannt ob es noch
verrückter wird mit dieser box also
reinschauen aber ich mache das jetzt mal
für die zuschauer ihr könnt das als
erstes sehen
taiwan und wir haben wieder ein getränk
ja geil taiwan ist auf jeden fall asien
wo liegt das in asien
ich weiß nicht wir haben das hier
gemacht den schuh ist der fake ist aber
alles ohne adidas habe ich ein bulle
gekauft kommt aus teilen made in taiwan
einfahrten also okay es sieht auf jeden
fall verrückt aus ich freue mich also
heute wird es glaube ich wieder sehr
ausgefallen das war bei den letzten
beiden parks nicht so ja und hier dann
wieder diese ganzen
beschreibung zu den ganzen sachen ich
würde sagen ich greife hintereinander
rein
wir fangen wir damit an teenager alter
kann ich die danach haben ja ja ja das
ist das im pokémon trainer wie nur ganz
krass so hier haben wir hätte nicu
das fühlt sich auf jeden fall sehr weich
an also ist ein gummibärchen bis vier
mal aufgefallen jetzt die ganzen
packungen aus anderen ländern einfacher
aufzumachen sind als in deutschland ja
das stimmt
das stimmt also nicht mal dran das
riecht ja so krass
hier kümmern ich traue mich gar nicht
auszuprobieren nicht meint nachher
schmeckt es dann ich weiß es nicht guckt
man die steuerung mittels oder es bleibt
vor allem zähnen kleben samtige katzen
frettchen sind ziemlich süß oder genau
wie diese notregierung die soften und
weichen weingummis in der sorte traube
kommen in den kleinen goldigen
katzenpfoten daher und sind mit einem
herbstputz ihr werdet es lieben
also ich nicht war das vielleicht dass
mexiko künstlich man machen wir direkt
noch weiter ich kann sie ja kurz schon
mal zeigen was zu trinken dabei juni
kannst du mal kurz übersetzten du warst
du mal in china oder das ist was ist das
für eine sprache walisisches lamm irre
ich mich jetzt gerade ich weiß nicht
leute wenn ihr es wisst schreibt gerne
in die kommentare
das ist fanta 4 mio graf kummer und das
sieht so richtig auch so richtig
asiatisch aus weißt du dann in den
geschäften muss sowas gibt links überall
und so und dann kannst du dir da
rausnehmen zu hoch wenn wir mal nach
japan wollen ja japan testen um es in
japan aber schon teuer so jetzt einfach
sagen oder ist das kalkül wenn die
spenden jeder kann stell dir vor ich
will könnte doch mal versuchen also ich
bin wirklich der letzte der von
irgendwem geld haben will oder sonst was
ich verdiene auch mit den youtube-videos
genug geld keine frage
juli hilf mir auch der kriegt auch mal
was von dem geld ab aber so eine reise
nach herab haben wir schon krass teuer
deswegen würde ich jetzt mal sagen das
ist ja eigentlich eine lustige idee so
ich habe ja auch noch nie irgendwie so
eine kanal mitgliedschaft gemacht oder
sonstiges wo man halt dann ein euro im
monat zahlen muss ich habe einfach mal
in die beschreibung ein paypal konto
geparkt wenn er bock habt könnt ihr da
gerne euro drauf spenden müsste auch
nicht und wenn das allein schon wenn
5000 leute ein euro spenden können wir
das hier machen und dann geile videos da
produzieren also natürlich nur mit der
begründung dass ihr dann keine videos
aus japan bekommen wir essen testen ich
hoffe das kommt jetzt nicht blöd drüber
oder so ist auch vollkommen in ordnung
wenn er das nicht macht aber mal eben 67
1000 euro für eine japanreise ist halt
auch für michael meier ist es sogar ein
bisschen billiger ich weiß ich kann mich
dann aus wir werden sehen schauen alles
klar
als nächstes haben hier nico engel soll
nach orio drin sein
lustigs wer gibt es nicht bei den heißen
temperaturen im sommer ein eis zu essen
das besondere bei caprica es ist kein
alles aber in deinem mund wir dass sie
eines schwarzen pkw packen ihre sachen
aus
schokolade ist hier so einzelrunde hier
sushi chips die schmecken nach sie
wahrscheinlich das maximum
also wieso lange jetzt keinen fisch da
drin ist also sushi mit mit paprika oder
so hat sich eigentlich ganz gerne der
reis gefällt mir zu schieben ist aus
schalke jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob
der nachschub schneck keine ahnung wo
narrisch mac aber definitiv nicht
auszuschließen oder ich habe irgendwie
noch nie richtige so viel gegessen sagt
aber eigentlich ganz lecker 80 ich will
davon jetzt nicht zu viel essen weil
dann wird mir schlecht also so viel
durcheinander das ist echt nicht gut
deswegen würde ich sagen wir nehmen erst
mal kurz einen schluck taiwanesische
fand daher was das für eine fanta ist
das werden wir jetzt erfahren
fanta double pietsch warum auch nur eine
sorte vier sich wenn auch zwei gehen in
dieser fanta befindet sich nämlich nicht
nur der weiße 40 sondern auch der gelbe
der ist doch rot
keine ahnung ich habe noch nie gewusst
dass es noch andere für sich auch in
erfrischend fruchtig und hier garantiert
nicht zu ergattern
also in deutschland einstellen 100 euro
reicher ich möchte nur nach fanta auf
mac problem war dass richtung greifbarer
eiskalt glaube ich ist das richtig
richtig geil können wir meinen
kühlschrank stellt aber schmeckt schon
künstlich ja auf jeden fall aber ich
würde es mir tatsächlich kaufen mit
merkel ja kanada weiter kommentieren das
gibt es täglich in deutschland oha also
die taiwanesische box ist bis jetzt mit
abstand die geilste mega waffel rollen
von oreo glaube ich solche die als
nächstes probieren kann man sogar noch
mal extra angepasst
sowas gibt es aber in deutschland also
es gibt auch solche ähnlichen
süßigkeiten hier so schmeckt das auch
also ist jetzt nichts neues wird nur
sagen
oder gar nicht so dass wie schmeckt aber
gut jede süßigkeit die wir hier drinnen
haben was für einen langen weg die schon
hinter sich haben
die kommen ja alle von vom anderen ende
der welt und werden hier bei alex video
auf youtube kanal ausgepackt deswegen
lohnt es sich auf jeden fall dieses zu
abonnieren
ganz wichtig und warten wir haben hier
aber gar nicht so viel das ist jetzt
schon das dritte video pilz ich kann es
aber gar nicht lesen 540 bringe pasta
gibt wohl jeder süßsaure pasta wie fiji
nitsch gummi auch das versprechen wir
die dünnen streifen schmecken nach
frischen süßen italienischen 40 unseren
zeitgleich ein wenig sauer sehen aus wie
nudeln schmecken die apfelringe nur hat
nach vier sich nehmen wir diese viele
gibt es doch bei manchen abzuringen
unklar
ich meine diese dinge zu euren rot und
gelb gestreift so das merken die eins zu
eins im körper jetzt hier den pick-up zu
probieren haben wir noch eine sache so
schokolade gibt jemand diese verpackung
von hinten das sie könnten lieber teuer
erklärte mainz in taiwan wenn diese
deutsche sachen auspacken und da gibt es
ja auch so what the [ __ ] ehrlich oder
weil diese sachen sind die abgefräste
als bei uns so dann hoffen wir dass wir
hier gute technik und haben hier jetzt
also wirklich wieder super verpackt
genies absolut gut für klimawandel ganz
viel platz die zarte schokolade umhüllt
hier ein fein stick aus cornflakes und
mangels dann nehmen wir mal sonst dich
hier raus ich meine ein bisschen wie
eine salzstange mit schokolade drumherum
teile ich jetzt nicht ganz so aber ist
ja und jetzt zum schluss haben wir hier
noch das sieht halt wieder ein bisschen
so aus wie diese koalabären
anteil hatten die es auch in deutschland
gibt und jetzt hat man hier so eine
brücke kiste praktisch die jetzt mal
kurz öffnen werde
das pokemon kenne ich gar nicht ist das
vielleicht ein pokemon doch ist ein
dokument habe ich persönlich will die
welt teilt das soll im juli sein oder
egoli pikachu vielleicht gleich das
recht auch das ist doch nicht das sind
einfach zwei aneinander
okay ich habe keine ahnung was mich
erwartet einer rechtlich franz max wie
komplex umfasst dann kann man das ein
bisschen komisch nach geschmack so dass
wir nun dieses i need nicht die
mini-krise crispy cookies ist kannst du
die kugel chris payr sondern otto happel
pokémon chocolate flavoured konkav sbo
gemeint war auch einer dieser hype sie
von asien nach europa gespielt wurden
selbstverständlich gibt es dort auch
süßigkeiten die dem süßen pickert zu
darstellen wen wundert's diese features
hier bestehen aus mais und verführen
euch mit ihrem schokoladengeschmack und
was ist das jetzt hier statt in pokémon
na ja welches dann kaka oder sonst kann
ich gar nicht mehr leute mehr haben wir
nicht das war es passieren ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen für weitere papstwahl
hat den daumen nach oben button folgt
mir hier auf youtube abonnieren blogger
aktivieren wir sehen uns morgen 19 uhr
wieder gibt es ein neues video haut rein
das war mit abstand die beste box bisher
ja das wird auf jeden fall
ich bin begeistert und ich freue mich
auf weitere boxen schöne grüße an snack
box immer her damit